vous avez confiance en vous je veux dire
vraiment confiant ce mois là maintenant
voilà d'ailleurs si j'avais écouté mon
penchant naturel je serais volontiers
resté chez moi ce soir
ça m'aurait évité un certain trac avant
de monter ici sur scène mais j'ai décidé
d'activer une demie ressources
c'est le goût des défis et la curiosité
aussi à votre avis quel pourcentage la
population connaît vraiment ses
ressources ses compétences ses talents
personnels
vous avez une idée la réponse c'est
moins d'un tiers des personnes
ça veut dire que entre vous et moi ici
ce soir
moins d'une personne sur trois seulement
connaît vraiment ses compétences pas
énorme mais comment se fait-il qu'on
connaisse aussi mal nos ressources
le cerveau de l'être humain est en fait
programmées pour se focaliser davantage
sur le négatif
les problèmes les failles les dangers
qui nous guettent et c'est d'ailleurs
fonctionnel c'est ce qui a permis
l'évolution si l'homme préhistorique
n'avait pas été attentifs à tous les
dangers qui le guettait de partout sans
doute qu'il n'aurait pas survécu
prenons un exemple plus concret
imaginons que vous êtes en train de vous
promener dans cette magnifique forêt au
canada vous admirer la beauté du lac
bleu azur la couleur des arbres des
montagnes vous entendez au loin le chant
des oiseaux vous sentez la sensation
agréable de chaleur du soleil sur votre
peau quand tout à coup apparaît en face
de vous un grill j
bon celui-là a l'air encore relativement
sympathique mais imaginons qu'il
s'approche de vous et vous fait face
d'un air menaçant
à cet instant précis vous allez
ressentir de la peur voire même de la
panique à ce moment votre champ
d'attention vos comportements vos
pensées vont se restreindre se focaliser
sur une seule dimension votre survie et
dans cet exemple précis où votre vie est
en danger
c'est évidemment une bonne chose que
vous soyez concentrer sur votre survie
uniquement et pas en train d'admirer la
beauté du lac bleu azur ou encore
d'écouter le chant des oiseaux
par contre si en permanence dans votre
quotidien à chaque instant vous êtes
constamment focalisés sur les problèmes
les dangers qui vous guette
alors là ce serait beaucoup moins
positifs sauf si vous avez des grizzlies
qui vous guette à tous les coins de rue
sait-on jamais
ce que les chercheurs en psychologie en
fait trouvé c'est que lorsqu'on ressent
une émotion négative comme de la peur de
la tristesse de la colère
alors en effet notre champ d'attention
se réduit se restreint et se focalise
sur une seule dimension
ce qui est intéressant c'est que
al'inverse lorsqu'on ressent une émotion
positive comme de la joie de la fierté
du bien-être alors celle inverse qui se
produit
notre show d'attention s'agrandit
s'élargit on devient plus créatif plus
flexible plus concrètement ce que ça
veut dire c'est que si vous avez un
problème à résoudre dans votre quotidien
et que vous arrivez à mettre de l'humour
ou une émotion positive dans cette
situation alors vous trouverez plus
facilement des solutions à vos problèmes
parce que vous prendrez en compte
l'ensemble des dimensions possibles
pas si facile donc de profiter
pleinement de la beauté de ce paysage ya
les dangers réels qui nous guette
mais il ya aussi l'état émotionnel dans
lequel on se trouve
au moment de la balade si on imagine que
vous vous êtes fait licencier la veille
de votre balade il ya de fortes chances
pour qu au lieu de subjugué par la
beauté du paysage vous soyez plutôt en
train de ruminer de ressasser votre
licenciement
imaginez maintenant pendant une seconde
ce que des personnes qui souffrent de
dépression d'angoise d'alcoolisme
pourrait percevoir dans ce paysage ya de
fortes chances pour qu'une personne
souffrant de dépression au lieu de voir
la beauté de ces montagnes elle voyais
plutôt ceux ci voire même si elle va
très mal
il se peut qu'elle voyais ça quant à la
personne
angoissé avant même l'arrivée du premier
grizzlies il se pourrait qu'elle voit et
déjà ça quant à la personne souffrant
d'alcoolisme et en manque d'alcool au
moment de la balade
il se peut qu'au lieu de voir des
montagnes et le voyais ça un doux
mélange en tant que psychologue
je me suis alors posé une question ces
personnes qui souffrent de dépression
d'angoise d'alcoolisme ou de
schizophrénie connaissent tel leurs
ressources leurs compétences ont-elles
confiance en elle pas sûr d'autant plus
que dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques on
s'intéresse en général davantage aux
symptômes des patients à leurs problèmes
dans l'idée de les réduire de les
diminuer
mais du coup on s'intéresse pas
tellement à leurs ressources leurs
compétences dans l'idée de les augmenter
les amplifier
et pourtant des études récentes en
psychologie ont montré que lorsqu'on
considère les ressources les compétences
chez un patient
alors ces symptômes diminuent plus
rapidement voici d'ailleurs comment l'
oms définit la santé comme en état de
complet bien-être physique mental et
social et pas juste l'absence de
pathologie ou d'infirmité si la première
partie la phrase peut paraître un peu
utopique ou difficile à atteindre pour
tout un chacun finalement ce qui
m'intéresse ici c'est surtout la
deuxième partie être en bonne santé
c'est pas juste ne plus avoir d'angoise
ne plus avoir de déprime c'est aussi et
surtout ressentir d état de bien-être
des émotions positives agréable c'est
pour cette raison que j'ai décidé de
m'intéresser plus uniquement aux
symptômes de mes patients mais aussi à
leurs compétences et alors j'ai décidé
de développer un nouvel outil qui nous
donne une sorte de photographie la plus
complète possible de l'ensemble des
ressources chez un patient au moment où
je me suis lancé dans cette aventure
j'étais assez naïve ou alors très
optimiste c'est selon en tout cas
j'étais sûr qu'il existait déjà plein
d'outils la sorte la réalité a été très
différente
ce genre d'outil sont très rares voire
même inexistant alors sur quoi est ce
que je me suis basé pour pouvoir
développer mon nouvel outil je me suis
basé sur les recherches empiriques qui
porte sur le bien-être le bonheur vous
allez me dire qu'est ce que c'est que le
bonheur vaste sujet en effet la science
la psychologie a tenté de répondre à
cette question et a constaté que pour
être heureux il faut trois dimensions
essentielles
la première c'est ce qu'on appelle la
vie agréable pour ça il faut augmenter
maximiser les émotions positives les
sensations agréables dans votre vie et
il faut minimiser dit
meaney et les émotions négatives la
souffrance le problème il y en a deux en
fait
le premier c'est que si je vous donne à
déguster un de ces succulents chocolats
le premier vous aime dire mon incroyable
le quatrième que je vous donnerai pour
est sympa et lorsque vous aurez manger
la boîte entière vous aurez une
indigestion
on s'habitue très vite à ce genre de
bonheur et le deuxième problème c'est
que il ya des souffrances des douleurs
dont la vie qui font partie de
l'existant c'est qu'on peut pas juste
décidé d'enlever alors cette dimension
si c'est une des dimensions du bonheur
c'est la moins importante des trois
c'est un peu la cerise sur le gâteau
alors quels sont les deux autres
dimensions pour être heureux la deuxième
c'est ce qu'on appelle la ville engagée
pour sa imaginons vous soyez quelqu'un
de drôle de créatif de curieux alors il
faudra déjà prendre conscience
identifier ses ressources en vous et
ensuite les utiliser dans votre travail
vos loisirs vos relations sociales
votre quotidien le plus souvent possible
et grâce à ça vous ressentirez davantage
d'engagement de passion
la troisième dimension c'est la vie
pleine de sens pour ça il faut des amis
une famille un travail qui donne du sens
à votre vie qui correspondent à qui vous
êtes vraiment à vos valeurs mon outil
découlent de ces trois dimensions
il se base sur un jeu de cartes pour
garder un aspect ludique qui motive les
patients en effet en a constaté que les
questionnaires classiques sont pas
toujours adaptés aux patients
psychiatriques
d'une part ils sont pas très motivant à
remplir et d'autre part pour des
patients qui ont des difficultés
cognitives ou langagière c'est pas
toujours très adaptée alors non on leur
propose de faire un jeu de cartes
ils trient les cartes en fonction des
ressources qui leur correspondent
alors qu'est ce qu'on mesure exactement
dans cet outil on mesure 30 est une
ressource différentes
la première ce sont les qualités
personnelles comme le fait d'être
curieux drôle optimiste la deuxième ce
sont les loisirs les passions comme le
sport les activités créatives
la musique est la troisième ce sont les
ressources externes comme les amis la
famille la nature une fois mon outil
créé je me suis rendu à l'hôpital
psychiatrique pour le tester et là je
suis arrivé tout contente avec mon outil
sous le bras et j'ai déchanté
parce que la plupart des patients que je
rencontrais me disait oula ça sert à
rien de faire cet outil avec moi moi
j'ai que des symptômes
j'ai aucune ressource et pourtant la
plupart des patients se laisser
convaincre is laissé prendre au jeu et à
la fin de l'entretien ces mêmes
personnes me disaient ah ouais vous
aviez raison c'est des ressources des
compétences que j'ai en moi c'est des
choses que je voyais même plus mais là
maintenant je vois alors comment est-ce
qu'on s'y prenaient pour aider les
patients à identifier leurs ressources
on leur proposait en fait de faire trois
tris de cartes différents dans leurs
preuves le premier on leur donnait
toutes les cartes dire leur disais parmi
ces ressources
lesquels sont présentes dans votre vie
j'ai par exemple rencontrer eve qui m'a
dit moi je suis quelqu'un de très
courageuse avec tous les événements
difficiles traumatisant que j'ai vécu
dans mon existence
si j'avais pas de courage je serai plus
ici aujourd'hui pour vous en parler
ensuite j'ai proposé à aig de faire un
deuxième tri de cartes
j'ai gardé toutes les ressources qui
était présente dans sa vie et je lui ai
demandé si ressources à quel point
est-ce qu'elles contribuent à votre
établissement
quand vraiment vous allez mal à quel
point elle vous aide à vous sentir mieux
la sève m'a dit sans hésiter la
reconnaissance elle m'a dit vous savez
j'ai déjà été hospitalisés huit fois
hôpital psychiatrique mon mari mes
enfants auraient pu abandonner depuis
très longtemps mais ils sont là ils me
soutiennent
il m'encourage et c'est ça qui me donne
une deuxième chance
c'est ça qui m'aide à me lever chaque
matin ensuite j'ai proposé à aig de
faire un troisième tri de cartes
j'ai pris les ressources qui était
présente dans sa vie celle qui était
absente et je lui ai dit parmi ces
ressources
est-ce qu'il y en a que vous aimeriez
développer ou renforcer davantage au
total on a fait passer cet outil à plus
de 200 patients qui souffraient de
troubles psychiques extrêmement sévère
chronique et les résultats obtenus sont
incroyables les patients qu'avaient les
souffrances les plus lourdes les
symptômes les dif les plus difficiles à
traiter avait également de nombreuses
ressources
voici les ressources qu'elle est plus
présente dans les qualités personnelles
la reconnaissance l'humour et la
curiosité et voici les ressources qu'il
souhaitait le plus développer la
confiance en soi
l'espoir est le fait d'être davantage à
l'écouté de leur corps l'autre chose
qu'on a constaté c'est que une fois que
les patients ont pris conscience de
leurs ressources
donc après une heure d'entretien ils ont
eu davantage confiance en eux ils se
sont sentis plus serein plus satisfaits
de leur vie il avait le sentiment que
leur vie avait plus de sens mais surtout
il se sentait plus heureux c'est grâce à
ces résultats obtenus qu'une vingtaine
d'hôpitaux psychiatriques en suisse et
en france ont commencé à utiliser ce
nouvel outil pour s'intéresser plus
uniquement aux symptômes de leurs
patients mais aussi à leurs ressources
d'ailleurs cet outil est adapté à tout
un chacun
on l'a aussi testé sur des personnes de
la population générale qui nous ont dit
ah ouais c'est vrai cet outil m'a permis
de prendre conscience de qualité de
compétences que je savais même pas que
j'avais d'ailleurs vous avez tous reçus
une carte de ressources qui en fait
caché sous le dossier de votre chaise je
vous laisse le temps de la découvrir
posez vous la question là maintenant est
ce qu'il s'agit d'une ressource que vous
avez ou d'un loisir que vous avez dans
votre vie si oui est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous activez que vous
utilisez dans les moments difficiles
quand ça va vraiment mal
est ce que ça vous aide à vous sentir
mieux et si c'est une ressource que vous
n'avez pas est ce que c'est une
compétence que vous aimeriez développer
renforcer davantage
si un jour vous traversé une tempête
comme ça peut arriver à tout un chacun
ou simplement que vous doutez de vous
prenez le temps d'identifier si
ressources ses compétences ses talents
qui sont les vôtres qui sont comme un
trésor qui ne demande qu'à être activés
pour vous sentir davantage serein
épanoui et heureux
merci
[Applaudissements]